i was like this is a little strange yeah
i mean but in my head i was like this
might be the most whack
wild like massage ever can you start to
work your way to his nipples yeah there
you go
[Music]
twist has nipples occasionally too
[Music]
how did it feel that when you walked in
the room
i think that was the biggest smile we've
seen from matt all season
uh you know it's an honor because i've
seen a lot of tough you know tough times
for matt to see him give me that big
smile it means he was happy to see me we
missed each other a little bit you know
we uh
we were separated for our first time in
forever you know i wondered that you
guys are roommates in nyc
what was it like to be apart from him
for all of filming
um honestly the house got cleaner uh the
food was better
cooked uh but no it was it was you know
it's good to have him around he uh
he brings so much good energy so much
positivity and some that can bounce off
a lot of questions and go through things
with so i missed them for sure
definitely missed them
you guys do have a really special
relationship how would you describe
the bromance um just someone that we can
both lean on
bounce each other bounce off you know
bounce things off of each
other um but that's my guy you know
we've known each other for now 10 years
we played college football together
we've been through a lot together he's
had my back in my tough times i've had
his back and uh
that's what a brotherhood's about and
i'm thankful for him well matt is your
bestie and
he and katie played quite a prank on you
on last night's episode
when did you suspect that this massage
was not normal
when the phone call came up i was like
this is a little strange yeah i mean
but in my head i was like this might be
the most wack wild
like massage ever like i can't wait to
go back and tell the producers how crazy
these people are here in farmington
you know and and then and then like i
kept like picking my head up and then
she would slam my head back down the
pillow you know oh and so
it was uh it was definitely interesting
i definitely was starting to catch on
and kept kind of peek up
and she kept throwing my head back down
and also i got these big
baby hands you know that was it did you
know they were matt's hands
yeah once i felt these big meaty paws
they're like long and like kind of
tingly like broken fingers from football
and all that stuff i knew
i knew it was mad i mean tyler at one
point katie had the masseuse um
twist your nipples yeah yeah you saw
that we all did
yeah i'm not dimple shy what did you
think of katie were you surprised matt
sent her home a lot of people are now
crying for her to be the bachelorette
really i mean i i think katie so far
from what i've seen has been a very
strong
strong like individual she's stood up to
the bullies of all the bs and i respect
that you know i mean she stands up for
what's right
so she became the bachelorette i fully
support her um i think she's done great
so far she's pretty girl
she's fun she's energetic she's
hilarious you know what else
you know what morbid you want it's
really crazy the journey that
matt was on to get to being the bachelor
looking back is it kind of wild to think
that he was going to go on clear season
um i just think it's a blessing he
didn't so uh i think he's right where he
needs to be
and um i'm happy for him so
when you knew he was gonna go be the
bachelor him being your best friend
were you at all worried well i was
definitely nervous for him because one
like i remember the first
two you know week week and a half i was
on the show i was in complete shell
shock for being around cameras for the
first time i barely talked to anybody
i was super timid so it was tough for me
so i couldn't imagine now like being
thrown in as the lead
you gotta carry this whole show you know
so uh
definitely was worried about him you
know worried for him about that i think
something else i was worried about was
like
where were you going to get matt what
was that going to be matt or was he
going to be a robot version of himself
trying to be mr perfect bachelor and
when i was there i was happy to see that
i got that and i got
you know the mat i knew so that was good
to see i think we're going to get more
of that as this show progresses and
grows
so i have a really important question
for you yeah how many
turtlenecks are hanging in matt james's
closet
there's a lot there's a lot of
turtlenecks you know he's a long-figured
guy so he likes to accentuate that long
neck of his with that turtleneck
um but you know so i get to steal some
every now and then so uh
it's good to have the closet we got a
good you know amount of those
okay yeah i mean are they turtlenecks he
took from the show or was the turtleneck
obsession even before the bachelor no it
was before we've had turtlenecks going
on for a while
now uh in new york you got to stay warm
you know so uh we have our
next we'll have an internal necks down
here in florida so but up in new york we
got plenty of them
um i am falling for you
okay the other critical question why
is matt james kissing people with his
eyes open
did you ever notice that before he was
on the show you guys hang out a lot i
mean i've seen him kiss like two girls
in the 10 years i've known him so you
know that's actually i i wanted to ask
you about that because matt has said
he'd never been in love before and then
he goes on the show
so did you think he could really fall in
love for the first time
on the bachelor i think the bachelor
you know pushes yourself more than you
normally would push
on a relationship and i think you skip a
lot of the bs steps
uh in dating and you kind of get right
to it so i think
if as long as you're willing to put
yourself out there and be vulnerable and
give it a shot i think that's a
possibility for sure
so why do you think he had never been in
love before we haven't really dug into
that with him yet
because matt is a very uh self-motivated
hungry person and i think
he his whole you know these last 10
years knowing him he's always been
trying to put himself in a better
position
you know i think his big you know goal
we always talk about is to have a family
and have you know a wife and kids
but i think he wants to prepare himself
to be able to you know
take care of that family take care of
those kids you know and set himself up
financially and
and be in a good place you know with
where he feels like work and life and
all that before he got to that so i
think now
he's in that spot he's in a good place
and he can actually really go go for it
and do it now
you guys are playing pool and matt tells
you do you see yourself
getting down on the knee at the end of
this thing i do
dude yeah wow yeah i'm excited for you
man this is thank you
my
[Laughter]
you looked a little surprised what was
going through your mind yeah yeah cause
i mean
i i'm something i'm gonna have to have a
roommate now and i'm pissed you know
like
you know he talked about me possibly
moving from the master bedroom to you
know
to the guest bedroom like yeah that's
fine as long as we switch the
red pay but uh but uh he uh
he's uh you know i was excited for him
you know it means that he's happy
because he's got a
group of girls that he believes in and
he loves those girls so that's good
so has matt moved a woman into your new
york city apartment
ah we're not allowed to do that yet i
mean listen we know that you're matt's
soul mate but
if you had to choose a couple of the
women who do you see going to the end
knowing
what you know about matt yeah i'd pick
anna
mj and victoria i don't think i'm gonna
get a straight answer out of you here
no uh chris harrison has said that
it was hard for him to tell what matt's
type was how would you describe matt's
type
matt's type i think matt's type is
someone who is going to be
you know willing to you know like matt
you know that he's got a huge heart
and matt loves to serve others and she's
got to be so much ready to help that
serve others with him
i think someone that is ready to pick up
and go and travel and be on the move
because matt is always moving always
going somewhere always experiencing
and living life to the fullest so we
need something like that we also need
something that you can sit down have
real conversations with and bounce
things off of
and so i think he'll find that i hope he
finds that well
matt said something to me about you just
last week when i talked to him
he said that he thought it was great
[Laughter]
he said you and hannah are in this place
where you're both cool with each other
and cool with each other being with
other people and he thought that was so
awesome and
i just wondered what's advice on how you
would get to that place for other people
how did you and hannah get to being in
such a good place
if you just care for the person as the
as a person themselves and not even just
the relationship part
we just care of each other as people you
know like we want each other to be the
best person we can be
and if that's you know being happy with
other people that's what we want you
know
matt told me he really likes hannah's
new boyfriend and he's met him do you
have any take on him i haven't met him
but uh she fishes i'm a good looking guy
so i'm happy for them
um now heather showed up last night
and heather said that she was there
because hannah told her
that matt would be the perfect guy for
her that she'd quarantined with you guys
and matt was perfect for heather what do
you think of that
guess not you don't think so
well we didn't see last night we didn't
see what happens i
what do you think i don't know i don't
know what happened so i haven't seen it
either so
would you have said heather's the
perfect girl for matt no because i don't
i haven't met the purple girl from that
yeah i don't i don't know
you know i matt's gonna tell me this is
it you know they don't believe
you have seen matt go through this
process being the bachelor there was so
much talk about you potentially being
the bachelor
would you do it at this point what do
you think no not not right now
i got so many things that i'm trying to
do for myself and
get myself a position where i want to be
in life that's not even really a thought
right now it'd be a great honor of
course like i think being ambassador is
a fantastic thing
but i'm very happy with what i got going
on in my life right now i just want to
build on that
and see where that goes okay